欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们 这一节课我们来讲一下店铺怎么样去规划来实现我们的寻盘目标
很多店铺它是没有一个阶段性的规划的
也不知道每个阶段要做什么事情
所以说导致它很多的事情都是没法落实到位
没有办法达成自己的目标
那么我们来记住一个原则 第二曲线原则
就是我们要时刻准备着店铺里面的第二曲线增长的产品
才能够保证店铺流量持续稳定的增长
很多人可能是做一到两个品类或者是一到五个品类
如果这些品类已经达到了天花板的流量
如果你不去拓充新的品类
那么你是很难让整个店铺的流量实现再次的增长的
这是一个非常高价值的一个思路
很多人就没有意识到这个问题
所以说他的店铺无论你怎么努力都是在原地踏步
我们来看一下这个店铺的流量增长模型图
首先这边呢是流量跟循环的坐标轴
从行业均值到行业优秀再到行业优秀的这个区间
那么这边的这条呢随着时间来推移我们店铺可能是在起步阶段
再到加速成长阶段, 到达了行业的优秀, 店铺起步呢就好比你做一个新店, 或者是说你的老店已经放置了很久了, 开始的时候你做店铺的时候是不是只有一到两个品类, 或者是三四个品类, 前期这部分的流量都是很少的, 是吧, 当他到达一定程度了, 你会发现, 诶, 我这个店铺的流量怎么没有增长呢, 我的寻盘啊, 还有访客都没有增长, 那么你在有限的指东西预算上,
下面是不是很难让你这个店铺流量再增长
那么这个时候你可能会考虑我从这里面继续集中资源去打爆一些产品
可能流量还会再增长,增长到一定程度可能就停止不前了
也就是在那个峰值的区间内波动
那么这种情况下我们就要考虑是时候拓展品类的
也就是在店铺里面拓展更多的品类
破产一些跟我们更加匹配的品类进行拉升全店的流量
这样那么就出现了第二条曲线
这个就是新品类出现
原来这些品类的流量加上新品类的流量
是不是你店铺的总流量就增长了
那么你是不是能够达到行业优秀的机会就更大了
因为行业优秀大多数的店铺都是在做多品类的
不可能是做1到3个品类, 或者是1到5个品类的, 他一定是做多品类的, 所以说他才能够跟这个行业优秀起频, 就按照这样的一个思路去不断的拓展, 品类到了, 又到下一个品类, 又到下一个品类, 品类里面一定要去做出大爆品才能足量的增长, 这里也是有了新的品类, 就要做出大爆品才能足量的增长, 按照这个思路去运营我们的店铺,
我们才能够更加持久的流量增长
那么最后面我们来理解几个概念
第一个就是每一个品类代表着一个人群
品类越多,覆盖的人群越广泛
成交的概率就会更大
第二个就是不同的产品覆盖的关键词是不一样的
店铺的总流量也是不一样的
第三个就是明确重要优先品类, 重点切入的品类, 然后去推广, 把资源集中到这些品类上面, 比如说你的订单, 群盘等等, 都集中在这些重点的品类上面, 才能够更加容易在有限的资源下, 把店铺的流量做起来
这一二三个原则一定要理解透彻, 同时根据这个逻辑去思考你的店铺要怎么样去做才能够快速的增长
那么这节课我们就讲到这里, 希望这三个原则能够给你带来更大的启发和衍生出更多的运营方法
那么我们下节课再见